there was a cloud that he created
immediately after the nfc championship
game regarding his future
in green bay and i was told at the time
that this was all about
rogers wanting a new contract not that
he necessarily wants more money shireen
but that he wants the kind of contract
that will bind the packers to him
and him to the packers for the next two
or three years the way it is now
at this stage of the deal it's a year to
year packers option
they can walk away at any time he won
the mvp last year
they're bringing him back this year if
he has a bad year this year
they can shift to jordan love next year
i think he wants the security
that would come along with a new
contract mike silver of nfl network the
cal connection
helps from time to time reports that
aaron rodgers
is obviously something he got straight
from rogers himself is talking to the
packers about a renegotiation of the
contract to free up cap space
now if it's a simple restructuring you
don't need to have a negotiation
you take whatever you do to make this
year you reduce his compensation
to one million dollars and change the
rest of it gets converted to a signing
bonus
and spread out over multiple years maybe
throw a votable year or two on the back
end
easy to do if there's a negotiation
that means there's something more
substantial than that and if i'm
rogers i may want more money
i may want i definitely want i know i
want
a guarantee a guaranteed salary this
year
and next year minimum i want to know
that i'm here the next two years i don't
want to be thinking about this jordan
love nonsense
every day every practice every game
that that i wondering if this is my last
season as the starter and i'm going to
am i going to have to find another team
next year
that's what i think he deserves for
being the mvp and i think that's what he
reasonably should want shireen
well mike the packers have signed no
free agents from outside the
organization
right so who knows if aaron rodgers
doesn't say to himself you know they've
done nothing to listen to me
to make this team better it's kind of
the
same thing that brett favre went through
before he left
maybe i don't want to be here after this
year maybe i want to go somewhere
else that's going to give me more say in
personnel and do more
to help me build this roster but i think
if we get a renegotiation here
or an extension or whatever is going to
happen with the contract i think that's
going to tell us a lot
about aaron rodgers future how long he's
going to be in green bay what the
packers think of him and what
he thinks of of green bay mike but i
could very well see aaron rodgers saying
you know what
this is not a situation where i can win
a super bowl i'm going to go so i'm
going to try to go somewhere else after
the
this year and win me a super bowl what
we really have forgotten about aaron
rodgers with deshaun watson and russell
wilson and
all the other turmoil and questions that
emerged from the fact that tom brady was
able
to go to a new team and win a super bowl
in his first try but
these are fair concerns and rogers
he's not going to like this but it's not
like he's watching anyway if you are
hello aaron welcome in and uh
we actually we actually want what's best
for you even though you may disagree
with that but
what what he wants is to never be the
villain he witnessed
what happened in green bay when brett
favre
who the packers no longer wanted the
packers didn't want him anymore
and even then he was the villain by
forcing his way out and ultimately
landing with the vikings so i think
aaron rodgers
likes to be able to send messages likes
to be able to be a little passive
aggressive
likes to be able to say i'm not doing
anything
i'm not saying anything to agitate or
politic or do anything other than show
up and play
and he's very very sensitive i believe
to the perception
that he's in some way the bad guy so
it's not
easy to work this out when you're
unwilling to take the risk
of being perceived as the bad guy
russell wilson willing to be perceived
as the bad guy
deshawn watson before the stuff of the
last week willing to be perceived as the
bad guy now is perceived as the bad guy
whether he
is willing to or not rogers i think has
been obsessed
with trying to thread this needle where
he gets what he wants he sends the
messages he wants to send
and there's never any fingerprints from
him
that that could reasonably be detected
suggesting that he's being unreasonable
selfish greedy anything like that and i
say all that
fully supportive of the idea that he
should get more that he should be upset
every packers fan should be upset about
the jordan love draft pick every packers
fan should be upset
that they package a four and a one to
move up a few spots to get jordan love
they all should be upset
what those guys could have done to help
that team get to the super bowl and win
it this year we'll never know
because they didn't do it so uh yeah
aaron rodgers should be upset
and this final contract will have plenty
of clues
as to how his attitude may or may not
have influenced the team
to to configure his deal in a way that
makes him happier
and i've said all along mike if he
didn't have the mvp season that he had
i think there was a really good chance
that the packers were ready to move on
from aaron rodgers after last season so
now this off season i think they
probably would have traded him somewhere
else but he came out and had the mvp
season
he's still playing at mvp level so at
this point you can't let him go
he he's the best quarterback in the nfl
he was last season he won the mvp award
so
you stick with aaron rodgers another
year but both sides
seemingly to me want that out after next
year but as you said
we're going to find out how this
negotiation goes down and what happens i
think it'll give us the clue as to what
the future of aaron rodgers is in green
bay
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports